hi everyone Alex Jen here for those that
are new to the channel I teach Aikido
and this is the first part in a series
of videos looking at stuff sparring so
there's a couple of reasons for the
purpose of this series the first is to
have a look at three different types of
stuff or jaws we call in Aikido which
can be used for sparring and second
aspect to see if any Aikido comes out
whilst respiring the three types of
stuff on comparing will be the variables
foam plastic and wood awesomer in length
that just over four foot which is about
hundred and thirty centimeters the foam
stuff is made from plastic piping with a
diameter of 2.5 centimeters with five
millimeter thick foam covering it
plastic stuff has the same tall width
the three point five centimeters however
it doesn't have any padding but does
have rubber stops on either end
lastly we'll be looking at the wooden
staff made from rotten which is two
point seven centimeters thick across
analysis we've tried to maintain as many
constants as possible so for example the
same pear spar with all three stapes
reviews same amount protection each time
and we've filmed it all on the same
evening we didn't do any grappling as a
focus to compare different types of
stuff the rules of engagement was
similar to Hima as when there was a
significant strike or thrust would
disengage and then continue we also
included after blows as this encourages
returned to a guard position so in the
next video we'll be breaking down the
form spar in reviewing it in slow motion
and analyzing what's happening I hope
you looking forward to this series if
you are make sure you subscribe give it
a thumbs up and hit the notification
button so you know when the next video
is coming out until then take care
you